we will take our next call we are taking
calls at 6 1 7 830 4750 our next caller
is from the 515 area code caller what is
your name and where you're calling from
today hello David my name is sanjeeva
from Ames Iowa I was just suggesting
that the fellow progressives to read an
article in The Huffington Post that was
posted about two weeks ago about a rural
strategy to win some of the depressed
district it was written by a man who won
like a very progressive like there was
like a referendum in Oklahoma to expand
what the corporate agriculture and he
beat it back by 20 points 20 points even
though Trump's and all the Republicans
like one space right overwhelmingly and
he's had some tips on how to run such
seat because I have a friend who work
for the d-triple-c and it seems Nancy
Pelosi and her ilk are just going to
give up on rural America soon yet I
don't want to remember and oblivion a
fixer do you remember any of the
specific s that are most interesting
from the article about how to win in
such a red district he said to focus on
monopoly power especially like on set
bike if Monsanto it's like the
agricultural and fertilizer monopolies
maybe even hit like the railroads which
have become very monopolized in the
rural areas so that so in when you do
that these voters often will vote with
you even though they might disagree with
you on abortion or guns or whatever
that's pretty interesting and it's so I
mean it's it's an economic and actively
it means applied oh yeah and actually
it's being applied by a burning
supporter who is running in Mike Pompeo
stir this district
Bernie supporters took over the Kansas
Democratic Party he's actually doing
pretty well the cokes are actually
nervous and they're pouring like
millions of dollars into supposedly a
really safe Republican see ya
fascinating I agree that that's a really
important issue thanks for pointing it
out and I hope people will check out the
article what's the easiest way to find
the article um I'm confirmed I'm trying
to remember if it was saying like The
Huffington Post had an article saying
how to turn blue states how to turn red
state blue and they let a guy named Jill
Maxwell got it got it okay very good we
will check into that really really
appreciate the call very very
interesting important topic particularly
going into the 2018 election